[Music]
take me back to when you first get this
role of Aquaman what did you want to
bring to the role at that time do you
feel like you've succeeded or is there
still more that you're dying to explore
everything that I was that Zack had come
up with
I was called in first time we have
definitely pulled it off
yeah there's death there's there are
moments that's our I would love to
explore
I think there's tons of room to explore
more and it would love to do it and in a
sequel but you know fans got to go I've
done a lot of them and people wanted the
other ones with me you hope they like it
and then there's definitely more we can
do you know they bring the classic soup
back for this film I know fans were very
excited about it's very important to
them to see Aquaman in that suit how was
it for you to see yourself in that suit
for the first time uh-huh
I've been using surreal a lot because
it's just it's very it's uh I can't
believe I am here I can't believe
Aquaman and it's it's it's it's a very
surreal thing so and the suit you know
when I first signed on Zack was like oh
no or not you know he's not there yet so
which was great I was like okay cool
there's a long road and journey to
becoming the king which I can dig I can
I like the idea of him being flawed and
and reluctant to being the king and you
know it's the last frames of our movie
he finally becomes that so there's a
whole new world of him just you know
owning up to being the king of Atlantis
when I put it on I didn't have a mirror
so I put it on and James was there in
the other room and then I walked out I
got to see his face and he's very
animated and very he's like me we're
both very similar where when we express
our joy we get loud and he was quiet and
I could just see his joy like blasting
out of his eyes
and he that was a huge deal for him to
get that right I mean it was trivial all
in his hands to get it right and I mean
like Heath it's it's his vision
now that you've rocked that one and the
Justice League one do you have a
favorite you know what I thought I would
have liked to Justice League one better
but I think I like the I think I like
the Aquaman the gold is pretty cool and
yeah I like that I like the Trident I
think that's a it's a you know finally
having the three prong and and just the
whole shape of it looking like a sword
and yeah it's like now Mike oh man now
I'm the king so how important was up a
conversation was tone in this film
because I feel like it is lighter it
feels funnier than than the previous
incarnations that we saw of you and
Justice League we were pretty I think
you know we want to make a smart ass we
wanted someone who punch Batman in the
face and question what a Wonder Woman
said we wanted to understeer the pot so
we definitely were our own version of
funny without being like why I mean I
don't want to be that I wanted to be you
know it was hard to play you know he
wanted the Outlaw Josey Wales he wanted
someone who was just on the outskirts
and very feral and that was fun and
that's a weekend and you know and you
know Arthur's life I was hoping that
fans would stick around that we could
get to this so that you can see why he
was the way that it was and you know
that's what that's what James created is
you know the intimacy of seeing what
he's like as a boy and then the moment
he leaves Jesse comes back home to his
father he's been on the road for a long
time running and hiding and you know his
he's coming home and having a pint with
his dad and then [ __ ] hits the fan again
and he's got to believe in himself but
it's all the people around him that you
know believe him to be King when he
doesn't himself so I think he needed
both of them yeah III like what both
directors did and I this is a total
different look I mean we're not we're
barely under water and in Zac's film so
this is all you know 50% of it's just
this road journey this road movie to an
end being on the water thing it has to
be vibrant like this I think it has to
those colours it's gonna be special
especially you know my mom and my family
in Iowa
cold and negative whatever and snow and
you're gonna go and see this I think
it's gonna you know in Russia and in
Canada in the northern hemisphere it's
gonna be a pretty awesome experience and
then everyone the southern hemisphere is
pretty stoked too because they're all
brown yeah I mean so it's it's uh it's
gonna be you know well it's it feels
like Australia and I mean like you're
gonna want to be you know it resembles a
lot of things that it's gonna make you
want to be there when you're in the cold
you know lastly we talked about
representation briefly but this year is
really much anchored by two films you
know comic book films featuring
superheroes of colour I'm curious how
important is representation in these
kinds of films right now I mean the
world's just is looking that way and I I
don't want to feel like it's all it's a
race thing and but I mean Black Panther
what a beautiful world and then in that
we can tell that story right now and
then it's it did so well that's
phenomenal
we haven't had that outlet Zak's a
genius to come up with the you know the
Polynesian race should be it Aquaman
could be half of that you know how that
feels for anyone that's you know the all
these interviews were talking people
from Argentina or Colombia or Malaysia
or Singapore and you know the islands
and it's just like wow what so many
brown-skinned half mixed race and I
didn't sign on to go like wow that's you
know that's the reason why as I need to
support that but it's it's gonna be
interesting how that affects the world
and and if I was you know my son's age
install this and I was you know my
wife's Jewish and black from the sixties
you know that's a pretty radical thing
and I'm like German Irish and Hawaiian
it's just the world you know I mean it's
not that it's like what I don't want to
be like I don't know I I just think you
know it's a special time for that and it
hasn't happened yet it's 2019 in a
second and very cool
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you oh yeah what are
you saying
something-something trident alright so
talk to me about when this role first
came to you did you leap at it cuz this
is unlike anything that you've done
before it's really nice to go into this
world in this way I have to be honest
about that it's kind of exciting way to
do it but no you're right I didn't
necessarily think that the call had gone
to the right person when I initially got
the call and Zach I remember speaking to
Zach Snyder who cast me in Justice
League with the idea that it could
potentially become Aquaman I remember
speaking to him and thinking you know
what about the superhero genre I'm
thinking hyper-sexualized kind of
limited archetypal roles that don't
really appeal to the kind of my
sensibilities or speak to the
complexities and nuances of the female
experience necessarily and he told me no
no not with this one this is a she's
mirrors a badass character she's no
damsel in distress she is a warrior
queen and I thought yeah I could I could
do I could do all right with a sword and
a crown all right
and I read the comic and I was
pleasantly surprised to find her just as
empowered and strong and fierce of a
character as he had alluded to you know
I meet her in the comic book and she
right in the first scene that I you know
meet her and Arthur alcaman and they're
after rescuing a coastal town she hears
a villager townsman and mistakenly
called her aqua woman and she stops in
her track and she is like no no I have
my own name my name is Mira I was like
Ana I can give Ana
yeah you know and speaking to that you
know when you think of a redheaded
princess who lives under the sea obvious
some people are thinking of an animated
Disney movie about a girl who's chasing
after a boy but this redheaded princess
who lives under the sea is fierce she is
badass she's dragging the man alongside
her you know how important
is it to have this version right now I
think this is the right time for this
kind of character this is the right
character for this time and this is the
right time to see her mara is could not
be coming into the world at a better
moment she is a badass fierce superhero
in her own right one who is independent
has agency has strength and takes takes
no crap you know she is a strong driven
unstoppable formidable partner in our
own sense equal to his so is this the
first time that one of your characters
has had an action figure as much as I
wanted there to be and all the boys love
Mandy Lane action figure I don't think
but is this the first time that you've
had it's to my knowledge yes I think
this might be the first time I've had an
action be thought it's well that's it
that's what surprised me I was like why
do I have to think about this this is
something one should just know I don't I
believe I this is my first experience
with being created into a doll is that
cool is that gonna be the holiday gift
everybody's getting mirror action yeah
I'm not quite sure how to approach that
I have you know a niece and nephews and
I was thinking am I gonna be that aunt
that's like yeah here's a doll of myself
or maybe I will me this is not lean into
it
what's so press about this film is that
so much of it takes place underwater but
you're not underwater and I remember
Jason was like yeah I'm moving sort of
like this and delivering lines was that
really how it was like that you have to
kind of move your body to being
underwater while you delivered your
lines and I'm just talking about like
how difficult is that even delivering
lines is difficult when you're thinking
about having to do it under the sea so
everything becomes more challenging
making anything look natural on camera
is is somewhat of a challenge if you're
acting and that should be the goal is to
make everything look natural or as
natural as possible but doing that while
you're attached to you know these really
strange harnesses and you're having to
play out all these action sequences
or fight sequences or stunts or even
just plain dialogue lines everything
becomes much more difficult when you're
doing it well suspended in the air by
you know two small thin lines I managed
by other people and every for me it
helped I did some training for this I
trained for many many many months
beforehand and a lot of my training
involved martial arts and as particular
kind of martial arts that incorporated a
lot of fluid movements and motions so
that I think that was helpful that's
cool what do you think about a Maris
spin-off movie I'm saying it right here
right now first mera hello why do people
need to go see Aquaman on the big screen
because that's the way to see this movie
the big screen is the way to see this
movie in this movie is a reason that you
go to the cinema this is a cinema movie
it is you know when I watched it I
watched it in the cinema with a full
audience and it was so much fun to just
see an experience and feel everyone's
the vibration of everyone experiencing
this whole world I mean this is a whole
world that James Wan has created Aquaman
is an adventure through a completely new
universe that we haven't seen before and
having that experience at the theater
that I can say for myself it was well it
reminded me of going to the movies when
you're a kid and being transported
that's what it reminded me of so you
have to see in the theater
the challenge meet for the throne my god
an ass-whooping
all right so so talk about armed in this
movie is he just like the ultimate
environmentalists or does he use that to
mask this kind of power-hungry side that
he has uh I don't think he uses it to
mask the power-hungry side I just think
that's how he is he has been brought up
I think that's what so his his his
reasons are very I think understandable
sympathetic and and justified meaning
that the surface world has destroyed his
oceans his actions and the way he goes
about it I think are definitely informed
by by having a mother and father had a
loveless marriage and a probably
terrible dad and said that's all he
knows is how to roll with with an iron
fist so or a gold fist or coral fist I
guess so now this isn't your first rodeo
with the comic book movie superheroes
what's it like sort of being on the
other side of the Cape you know which is
more fun playing to hear yeah I'm it's
listen I'd these are if this is all I
ever do I mean knowing that my film
Canon includes dan dreiberg enormous
pretty awesome I mean I'm so so
fortunate to they're such great eclectic
different kinds of guys I mean this just
because of the nature of the filming was
such a different beast and and because
of the Aquaman I mean with with Watchmen
I I I actually had very little green
screen work it was very practical and
and and so it never felt strange it
always felt very grounded this is you
know when you're hanging in wires for
most of your scenes it just was a
completely different experience so
they're vastly different I just traded
in the cowl for a ocean master I talked
about shooting some of that stuff
because your character pretty much the
whole time is underwater you know and it
looks so incredible sort of when it's
realized but yeah how complicated was
that on set like what what were you
doing that you had never done before
that you had to add on as an extra
layers to everything uh was something I
had
before I I I mean that being said you
know acting is acting and I I've done a
lot of different kinds of genres and
different roles and I come from the
theater so not none of that stuff scares
me the language the melodrama the
theatricality of it the operatic nature
of this guy that that doesn't scare me I
like to rise to the occasion to that the
technical aspects absolutely I mean I we
we've never done this kind of fighting
before most people haven't done this
even our stunt team at have done this
amount of wire work and when you're just
even doing a two page dialogue scene and
spouting out these monologues while
you're in some kind of a harness flying
around the room trying to look like
you're swimming it just felt like some
weird avant-garde theater III gotta say
it was Willem and I may because it's
Willem and he's such a great actor and
from the Wooster group that he's he that
you you really did feel like you're
doing some strange theater um but I
loved it because it actually made you
really concentrate on the other actor
because you weren't getting lost in
something else
you only got each other cuz there's
literally nothing else around you meet
him and Dolph you know sort of flying
around the room together you know talk
about your relationship with James Wan
you've been together with him for a
while I feel like that relationship
between actor and director is one that
not enough people talk about and what
what what what is it like being with
James and why is that relationship
specialty um I think any any time I
think the trust that you have in your
actors and your directors is is is is
paramount it's so important can it be
done like that and in one movie shore
and I've had some great relationship of
directors I've only worked with once I
think with James mamada of comfort in
working with someone but there's also I
know that he's going to push me I know
that I'm going to demand the most out of
him and ask tons of questions and he's
going to demand the most out of me so
when you have that kind of working
environment it it keeps your creative
juices flowing it's not like we are we
get along so we're like
we got this this will be easy it's we're
excited to get to work and I saw if I
look at you know for us and that shot or
whether it's Kurt Russell and carpenter
or you know certainly De Niro and
Scorsese and now DiCaprio and Scorsese I
think there's those that there's
any relationship you just want trust you
know an actor just wants to feel
comfortable comfortable that I'm gonna
put myself out there and you're not
gonna you're gonna take that and go
further with it and not judge it so I
think he certainly brings that out of me
and I hope I bring it out of him it's
the exact spot that vocal gave me my
first woman lesson not even close
you have to forget all the teaching of
the surface world go deeper one covering
your Atlantean instincts
this is not your first rodeo with with a
comic-book movie you were in the first
three spider-man realms what's the
difference between the two experiences
oh you know there is different as the
directors different as the principal
characters what I have to do in the
movie is very different and so much has
changed as far as the level of effects
and this is it's hard to compare i I
don't have any fun comparing them I mean
I live it so I don't have to make the
comparisons but this certainly you know
is yeah it's hard to connect it to
spider-man for example the other
favorite spies you know having been
apart though a big part of these two
different errors of comic book movies
how would you say they have evolved
since you did those well certainly the
effects have gotten very differently
have developed a lot more certainly the
the scenes in this are more spectacular
spider-man had a very strong story and I
think that series was a beautiful series
of movies particularly the very first
one characters were very strong on it
was a beautiful mix of comedy and drama
this has those elements to the big
difference is the size I think this is
really muscular and huge and spectacular
it's more like a fantasy film yeah you
know speaking of the size James Wan she
had a photo of you recently a vocal
riding a giant shark how do you see a
photo like that you like that's it I'm
good I've ridden the Giants are good
yeah no well of course when I'm shooting
and I'm not riding on a giant shark and
I'm shooting on some green and knock you
see here would be a no but that's where
the pretending comes yeah is that what
that is that what they put you on for
that like what are you on a cube yeah
basically basically yeah but you know
there's there's a lot of why you're
working this for me and that was fun and
I knew that
we were gonna do that because when you
have strong physical tasks and fought
strong physical challenges
it really roots what you're doing it
roots the pretending and got to do
spectacular things yeah I mean maybe you
can't tell in the finished film so much
but you know sometimes 60 feet up in the
air and able to dive down to just inches
of the floor and you know do barrel
rolls and things like that yeah it's
it's a lot of fun it's gotta be wild
yeah I love the complexity of volcko
because this is a guy who physically is
sort of aligned with arm but I feel like
in his heart he's aligned with Arthur do
you think this is a guy that knows
exactly whose side he's on or do you
think he's torn he's torn but you know I
don't want to give too much away I mean
his position is he's working two sides
against the middle and I also think in
the course of the movie maybe he changes
because in in there's some flashbacks in
the movie I don't know what to say and
what I can't say but in the flashbacks
in the movie he's a little skeptical
about what what Arthur's talents may be
Arthur really comes into his own but
volcko is kind of old-school Atlantean
and he learns a lot from and and he's
surprised by Arthur yeah ah the Aquaman
character because he really does come
into his own and he also teaches Valco
something about the surface people and
it has a lot to do with the fact that
he's got this kind of compassion this
human compassion and this kind of live
and let live easiness that allows him to
you know understand how the two worlds
can not coexist peacefully and volcko
maybe old school and may be involved in
the intrigues of civilization that he
saw rise and fall but he's kind of
coming around he's coming around to a
new way of thinking and anyway
anytime that happens that's cool and
he's a great mentor
I got a Karate Kid vibe yeah you got a
little mr. Miyagi vibe you get a little
taste of him you know imparting some of
the wisdom of the old culture to Arthur
when he's a young guy
I feel like you're a guy who's mastered
the horror genre you delivered my
favorite fast and furious installment
why a superhero movie and what did you
learn from doing those kinds of films
that you brought here ah
why is superhero movie uh you know I'm a
big fan of sort of spree hero comic
books growing up or just comic books in
general growing up and you know and
obviously the the Alpha chim to heat the
chance to do a character that's never
been done before it was very exciting
for me you know yeah there's a few
superhero movies out there in the
landscape of superhero films but but the
the opportunity to play with a guy that
the wise and has never kind of really
quite seen before was was what was
exciting and and also the opportunity
for me to to do a wall creation film
that was something that I've wanted to
do for the longest part you know so you
inherit this version of the character
from Zack Snyder when when that happened
what did you look to bring to Aquaman
that maybe we hadn't seen yet injustice
yeah you listen I you know I was sort of
I was involved in the in in that process
early on when they were in the mid so
farm you know cooking up Justice League
and and so you know so it was something
I was mindful of I was aware of what
they were doing and and and realizing
that that ultimately I'm picking up the
character way you know where they leave
off with Justice League and that the
thing that I wanted to kind of make sure
that I could do was make it an origin
story without it being a prequel but
what's so cool about where I picked up
the character of the stud is you know he
starts off as alone it's that's out as a
guy that kind of doesn't quite fit in
right into either walls and he keeps to
himself is great because it allows me to
then take him on this hero's journey to
becoming more accepting of who he is and
becoming more accepting of the two
different worlds and and realizing that
he's actually the best of two worlds you
know he brings back the iconic suit in
this one was that always there from the
beginning whose decision was it to bring
from the very beginning I want
to put in the the hero suit the classic
sort of suit from the comic book and and
and and even like he's sort of classic
you know old-school trident as well you
know the try and obviously for me in
this was his Excalibur you know King
Arthur in such a bisque Excalibur was
basically my my stuff plot narrative now
Jason talks about wearing that suit for
the first time not seeing himself in it
but seeing your reaction seeing him in
it when you saw him in that suit for the
first time how did you feel did you feel
like here's Aquaman yeah I mean you know
like for the longest part when you're
designing it you know you're designing
it on paper in a computer sort of
context and then when you know when you
make it it's on a mannequin right and
you so putting together it's automatic
it's like okay that looks cool but then
when you put it on the person that you
made it for put it on a human being and
ultimately it's Jason Momoa that the
that the costume was made for I mean it
just literally the character just came
to life and I just couldn't believe it
and and it was a pretty incredible
moment yeah it made me kind of go okay
you know what all the effort and time
and energy it took to get the suit right
to get it looking cool was was the right
thing to do you know not only do I feel
like this is the most ambitious DC movie
I feel like it's also the one that has
the most fun how important was tone as a
conversation starter coming into this
film in terms of you know having that
humor having that lightness having that
breezy kind of feeling to it I I said
that from day one when people would
interview me you know when I was just
starting out making this movie and I
said I want to make a fun movie and
everyone really was giving me crap for
saying oh he's saying the buzzword fun
I'm like no no like I don't really know
any other way to make an Aquaman movie
and not have it be fun and adventurous
and be a bit tongue-in-cheek you know
and cheeky at the same time I feel like
that's what the comic book was and you
gotta acknowledge that you gotta lean
into that and and just and go for it you
know I also loved the fact that Julie
Andrews does a voice in the film I've
said that uh when I was designing the
Khorasan creature which is my own voice
the Kraken you know I you know I wanted
the most powerful creature on earth to
be to be a female character rightfully
and and then the next step was for some
reason I kept thinking that I want to
keep thinking she I keep hearing British
for some reason and I can't wait to get
to be British so so you know I started
you know could I flip you know putting
kind of names together and and you know
and I the names that sort of put
together where Dame Helen Mirren Dame
Judi Dench and then Dame Julie Andrews
and and very fortunately for myself that
I I think you know Julie told me this
that she said her grandson is a big fan
of my work and a big fan of these films
and and really wanted to see you know
grandma in this room and so I said I
really have him to thank for that and
you know and Julie was just amazing I
mean I just can't believe it when I was
directing her that I'm like oh my god
I'm directing Julie Andrews what was it
like have you watched this film with an
audience yet complete and I'm just
curious to know um I've you know I've
watched a few times
Jim you know test screenings and stuff
like that and I always get very nervous
and anxious with all my films about
watching it with an audience but but you
know it's a I think you know this movie
was designed to be a crowd-pleaser and
so it's a fun one to watch for an
audience just like my horror films yurui
I make my movies for for you know for so
that's like the big communal crowd and I
really think it's how it needed to be
enjoyed Anna and with the the Vista and
the visual of the film it really needs
to be experienced on the biggest screen
if you can what is there someone who
surprised you the most in this film in
terms of your cast I mean I knew I mean
all of them are fantastic but I think
you know a lot of people were actually
pleasantly surprised at how awesome
Dolph Lundgren was and I'm like not for
me I was like I always knew that he was
amazing and that's why I cost him in
this and and dolf is great you know like
you know even growing up with fire just
always movies in the past you know I
remember watching him and Johnny
mnemonic and then go WOW Dolph is so
charismatic in this role he's soaked
in this film and you know and no he's
kind of you know I had him in the back
of my mind and and when it came down it
came time to cuss this roll you know
offer you know of an elder statesman
king but who potentially was a great
warrior at one time you know a great
powerful King you believe that Dolph
could play that character and in Dolph
is great I mean everyone was great I
Nicole Kidman is amazing and this was my
first movie with Nicole and I feel very
fortunate to have worked with her
you